this is a way of taking all your
frustration out yeah and you're a seed
Alex needs all the help you can get and
I want to see if any of his kitchen
staff have hidden talents for each of
you to make a pizza whoever has the
best-tasting pizza will put it on the
menu tonight as a special I've
discovered that Joe the kitchen porter
has trained as a cook artichokes cream
peppers black olives okay Joe here we go
excuse me Joanna comics are just rice
and pizza with this mate
thank you here we go right Joe just
explain to the lady what we done have
you got two seconds who has made these
amazing pizzas what this lady's come to
taste them would you come in and just
take them with us you know like your man
you'll go undernourished bring on the
pizza Alexandre and I bet you're a
vegetarian how long have you been
staring what I didn't realize was that
al Donna put Parma ham on the base of
her mozzarella tomato pizza Carla and
which one do you actually prefer the
last one I would go for that one the
mozzarella one mm-hmm
unfortunately that's got lots of
mozzarella and tomato but underneath
that it's per half
there you go you converted a vegetarian
would you like some more no thank you
oh no you have come at a big rush good
luck with the Vegemite fresh food on the
menu marks a new start for Lantana but
it's gonna be a huge step I'm burning
all traces of plastic sources from the
premises now Alex will have to cook from
fresh in an attempt to slow Alex down at
the kitchen I'm cutting his menu by half
why have you got free chicken dishes on
choice yeah well I've seen all three of
them and I think they're all [ __ ] you
know that because it will conquer the
same [ __ ] sauce two of them can go
and I'm not doing that or saying that to
put you in a [ __ ] but you are in a
position to regenerate rejuvenate those
customers and put a little bit of
freshness and lot of excitement to your
customers you know that with a limited
menu and some new dishes tonight is
Alice's big chance to prove to me that
his capable of cooking from fresh
it's something I'll expect one of my
most junior chefs to pull off without a
hitch a check on one prawn cocktail two
parmigiana 1 soup first ever since and
all valence goes like this Jesus Christ
that everyone gets really dizzy slow
down I want to really make sure that you
stay nice and calm yeah yeah but show
some composure now but the kitchen is
only half the story for the evening to
run smoothly the dining rooms got to be
well managed by the maitre d